zweimal
wir haben eins gesetzte schnitte 1 hier
steht eins plus extras ist ja eins
cosinus computing ist cosinus hockey der
cosinus ist bei 21 ist es bei diesem 1 0
maximilian janisch ist elf jahre alt und
löst mit seinem vater eine mathematik
professor im ruhestand mathematische
aufgaben auf universitätsniveau beiden
differenzieren
mir gehen sie mal funktionen meistens
zweidimensional auf welcher stufe wird
das unterrichtet gelehrt
das ist meines erachtens zweite oder
dritte und zwar alle messen und zwar ist
dass die abschlussprüfung
das sollten sie müsse es von 2010 2014
ist die letzte abschlussprüfung
das ist kein problem für dich die ich da
ich bis jetzt gerade nicht aber die von
rhi lenz schon da fühlen wir uns fast
veralbert und maximilian
intelligenzquotient liegt bei 149 plus
das heißt er reizt die gängige scollo
aus wie lebt es sich als hochbegabter
und wie leben eltern mit deinem
wunderkind davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
hoch 1 gotthard crosslauf
mein erstes zusammentreffen mit
maximilian janisch findet anlässlich
einer konferenz in genf statt thema die
zukunft des lernens maximilian ist aus
redner eingeladen zusammen also wir
haben einen text geschrieben sagen immer
so entlang dem bus geht also er hat ein
prototyp geschrieben hab ich dann
verbessert da hatten wir den übersetzen
lassen und dann haben sogar ihre karten
aus dem radio oder wieso hast du hier
ihr kommen können also wir haben uns
nach einem kleinen kampf wie immer mit
der schule
wir haben öfters mal so kleine
ausstellung sag ich mal haben wir frei
bekommen und wenn die auch sehr nett
weil wir kriegen wir oft dass menschen
immer zu fern sind oder wenn sie dinge
und dann kriegen wir halt einen
sonderfall und das finde ich noch
angewachsen und wir finden
du bist ihr seid ein wir also wir drei
eigentlich mit der mutter die es im
office ist leider gottes in seinem
referat redet maximilian von seiner
schulkarriere die er im schnellzugstempo
absolviert hat die malschule in drei
jahren mathematiker mit neun förderung
an der universität zürich
[Musik]
mein weg war nicht immer einfach aber
ich hatte immer menschen um mich die mir
halfen
ich glaube die gesellschaft hat die
verpflichtung alle kinder individuell zu
fördern
hochbegabte und normal begabte zögern
sie nicht zu fragen
der elfjährige maximilian besucht die
dritte klasse des gymnasiums immensee
seine klassenkameraden sind 14 und 15
jahre alt jeden mittag holt ihn sein
vater thomas drescher aus erster ehe
vier weitere kinder hat in der schule ab
und bringt sie nach hause ins
luzernische meierskappel maximilians
mutter ist promovierte betriebsökonom in
das gemeinsame mittagessen und pflicht
für jeden tag ihre arbeit ich relativ
nah sie um gymnasium oder
vollumfängliche betreuung und da auch
wintergäste und das hätte man wirklich
tot sei dicker und darum pflegemutter
twitter und was sowas optional zukunft
lassen arbeiten gibt so viel zu tun wie
gut ich finde meine begabung liegt darin
dass ich dinge schneller begreifen als
viele andere als der durchschnitt und
meine hauptpunkten der mathematik dann
bin ich am schnellsten und begreift
vielleicht auch manchmal dinge die
anderen nie begreifen werden
es gibt leute aber es liegt vielleicht
auch damit dass diese leute sicher auch
nicht mit einmal täglich
auseinandersetzen
auf einer lernplattform acht maximilian
heute gymnasiasten für die matura fit
seine hochbegabung zeichnete sich erst
nach der einschulung ab er übersprang
klasse und klasse und landete mit acht
jahren am gymnasium für sie war klar
dass er sich langweilt in der schule ja
kein ausdruck kein ausdruck ja wir
hatten ja auch so genannte hausaufgaben
dann saß er am küchentisch und also
gelder vor sich hin
das machte keinen sinn also in der
biografie beschreibt er dass er jeden
tag bis 20.10 musste und dabei musste
also eine billion ist es macht dich und
dann fingen sie an zahlen zu agieren mit
überschlag 75 oder so also ewig ein
psychisches einziges gefängnis hat man
ihn dann nicht auch so zusätzlich
gefährdete schwierigeren aufgaben
überhaupt nicht im grunde ist dieses
management wie das heißt zumindest in
den schulden in maximilian war gar nicht
möglich weil die kompetenz und
vielleicht auch die ressourcen fehlen
also es gab dann das ifs denn sie
vielleicht integrative förderung
das war der absolute wille da hätte
eigentlich an maximilian die lehrerinnen
unterrichten müssen
das war müll die frage vom hochbegabte
kinder und der umgang mit dem eine
hochbegabte bringt das polarisiert zu
100 prozent
es gibt dir wo es genau für richtig
halte dass man hochbegabt frieden
fördert und es gibt die andere seite die
ältere sind spinnen die verwirken sich
auf dem rocker vor dem vor dem gericht
dass wir brücke zum erfolg das ist die
klassische eiskunstlauf mutter fatah
satz wo ist einfach das rind eigener für
die eigene ambitionen ist braucht aber
das habe ich mir wieder lernen ja dass
dies die genau gehen nur die zwei mal
einige gibt zu dem thema da gibt es
nicht kein graubereich zwischen und das
ist mit der herausforderung sich
zumindest als lernende mit ungeheuer
mit neun jahren machte maximilian dem
mathematiker mit bestnoten
die matura in den anderen fächern steht
ihm noch bevor
nachdem die eta die aufnahme verwehrt
hat fährt er alle zwei wochen an die
universität zürich wo ihm der renovierte
italienische professor camino del ist
ein speziell auf ihn zugeschnittenes
förderprogramm anbietet die begabung von
maximilian ist so außergewöhnlich also
ich habe mir früher jemand gesehen der
in diesem alter die höhe der mathematik
verstehen kann so gut wie maximilien es
ist eine ganz große ausnahme
irgendwo erfahrung camilo dallas war
selbst und wie die 129 jahren
ordentlicher professor
aufgabenstellungen wie diesen war er
aber erst mit etwa 14 jahren gewachsen
im gegensatz zu maximilian durfte der
ließ keine klassen überspringen und
bewegte sich stets unter gleichaltrigen
interesse für die mathematik darum dass
die höhere mathematik kennt und so
weiter ich denke das ist ziemlich gut
für ihn also das wäre ja auch gut für
mich gewesen und ich hätte das sehr
gerne gehabt
maximilian bezugspersonen sind
ausnahmslos älter aussehe
sein professor an der uni seine eltern
seine 14 und 15 jährigen
klassenkameraden am gymnasium
stell dir vor er wäre jetzt in der
sechsten klasse der privatschule
meierskappel welches interesse würde mit
den anderen finden teilen nichts
überhaupt nichts setzen auf die videos
zu sprechen wäre oder auf die kosmologie
ist jetzt egal was würde er keinen
ansprechpartner finden dass das problem
besteht
egal ob die anderen ihre gleichaltrige
oder älter sind und es besteht weniger
die eltern sie sind ein zehnjähriger an
der uni stoff für ein buch dachte sich
ein welcher verlag und bekundete
interesse an maximilian biografie als
ghostwriter beschreibt der 69 jährige
thomas tritsch den kampf der familie um
eine adäquate förderung maximilian die
hauptbotschaft des buches könnte man wie
folgt bezeichnen die besonderen talente
zb im sport tanz in der musik werden
tatsächlich in der schweiz ausreichend
gefördert es gibt wenn ich das richtig
in erinnerung habe
23 sportgymnasien in der schweiz die
besonderen talente in den mint-fächern
mathematik informatik
naturwissenschaften und technik haben
diese möglichkeit nicht
wie du weißt und da ziehe ich mich
gerade einer stressigen aufgabe bist du
zufrieden mit einem ghostwriter
das kann man sagen ich bin zu reden ja
vollkommen siehst du dich in diesem buch
erkennst du dich david oder sind das die
gedanken eines von der buch der
buchtitel lautet ich bin doch quasi kein
phänomen aber du bist schon ein phänomen
naja wie diese mit diesem talent mit
dieser begabung war also kommt darauf an
was man als foul bezeichnet wir haben
wir ein fragezeichen dahinter gesetzt
man kann streiten wie bon jovi setzen
sie seien das phänomen das phänomenale
an maximilian ich behaupte ja es gibt
wahrscheinlich tausende von kindern
ähnlicher vergebung das phänomen
entsteht verbandes als phänomen
bezeichnete dadurch dass maximilian in
einem umfeld aufwächst
aber dieser begabung optimal rechnung
getragen werden kann
jetzt die gewalt ist in den
frühlingsferien begeben sich vater und
sohn auf eine buch promotionstour nach
paris drei auftritte bei großen
französischen fernseh und radiostationen
stehen auf dem programm
[Musik]
in drei minuten beginnt ein live
interview im radio
was maximilian nicht im geringsten
beunruhigt werden dem ich im fond das
war uns doch etwas zieht erste station
und eine live sendung auf französisch
keine große sache für maximilian die
seine ferien nie was in südfrankreich
auf dem anwesen seiner eltern verbringt
und dort mit den nachbarskindern
gespielt und nun französisch spricht
du bist 11 maximilian herzlich
willkommen hast du einen besten freund
deine freundin ja sie heißt wie alt ist
ich glaube jetzt 14 sagt dir
gemeinsamkeiten
aber das kann man so nicht sagen war so
dachten so aber ich verliere in der
schule immer meine blätter
sie lässt mich irre kopieren
was sagen wir der trägerin maximilian
ist gewieft im umgang mit medien ganz
gut also ich bin sehr souverän wirklich
ja ich würde auch sehr zufrieden aber es
verschafft fertig wird und sagen du
willst du mir das gleiche gefragt welche
frage nervt ich am meisten
ich weiß nicht so wirklich es ist
einfach fragen fragen hat mich ja
meistens nervt einfach irgendwann die
monotonie da fragen was sollten die
journalisten fragen welche fragen
würdest du gerne beantworte nachts weiß
ich nicht aber ja einfach andere fragen
mal neue fragen zum beispiel ich hab
kein beispiel weil ich kenne nur die
fragen die mich schon gefragt worden
also womit die fragen die andere schon
mir gefragt haben
aber ja zum beispiel was machst du in
frankreich verso das hat mich noch
keiner gefragt was machst du so lange
gereift ja ich spiele dort mit deinen
freunden
tasch trapp trapp und rampen und sonst
programmier ich manchmal ein bisschen
was aber machte
der nächste interview termin steht erst
morgen auf dem programm
zeit für ein bisschen shopping
[Musik]
der verlust nicht
hab ich aus
das habe ich nicht nötig das liest du
gerne ja das kann man sagen
was findest du so tollen ausblick ich
find den textur von schuld und ich denke
ich habe mir gedacht du liest so die
dicken schinken irgendwelche romane
das ist mein leben natürlich sehe er
jetzt was hat der dichter und denker
vor allem auf den 1 die moz in
eiffelturm morgen ein hocker
sagen wir mal sie haben ja noch vier
andere teams so ist es ich denke aber
diese vaterschaft unterscheidet sich
fundamental von den anderen zunächst
unterscheidet sich ich sage mal der
mainzer der gesellschaft
das was wir jetzt machen wäre damals als
abscheuliche abscheuliches elitäres
gehabe klassifiziert worden
das war gar nicht möglich zu einer
schule zu kommen sagen der bursche
langweilt sich da einfach nicht eine
klasse überspringen
das war gar nicht möglich aber ich hatte
auch eine frau die gegen das
leistungsprinzip war sie also jetzt mehr
darauf achtete dass es für die
jugendlichen und früher für die kinder
wirklich ein leben mit vielen
glücksmomenten ist selbst mit anders
das heißt dass sie daran dass sie war
sie auch ein leben mit vielen das glück
am meisten wenn man mit aller kraft die
man zur verfügung hat zu einem ergebnis
gekommen ist der augenblick der völligen
erschöpfung
das ist für sie glüht ja denken die das
ist für maximilian auch so ja das denke
ich ja was darum auch in paris nach
einem langen tag nicht fehlen darf die
tägliche übung stunde mathe für
maximilian das intro zu fragen und
mindestens ein sektor ist wie ich hatten
wir alle abteilungen nicht mehr
anschauen was man tricks maximilian aus
ihrem pensionsalter projekt zu
bezeichnen würden sie wahrscheinlich
auch etwas unverschämt bezeichnen oder
also um das missverständnis ganz
auszuräumen
ich habe auch weitere projekte ich habe
zb drei bauprojekte im augenblick ist es
nur ein beispiel
in gewisser weise kann man noch die
biografie von maximilian als eine in
diesem fall gemeinsames projekt
bezeichnet also wird geht idee er würde
man sagt das habe ich ja auch schon
ausgeführt
man konzentriert sich ausschließlich auf
das eigene kind dann wird im kind keinen
gefallen getan
man kann schon sagen ich bin schon ein
projekt fällig und du bist ein
riesenprojekt und ein projekt das spaß
macht was halten
bist du gerne ein projekt ich bin sehr
gern trägt ich meine jetzt jedoch ein
bisschen aufmerksamkeit
am nächsten morgen wegen eines streiks
beim staatlichen fernsehsender ist das
geplante interview ins wasser gefallen
deshalb ein abstecher in den body
bologna
das hat kein motor nicht als reines
wasser das nicht so fahren bringt wie
würdest du deine beziehung zu dann worte
beschreiben ja ich würde sagen sie ist
schon ziemlich eigen er ist eben wie
schon gesagt mein vorbild mein vater
mein förderer und man auch meine mutter
also was magst du am liebsten und einem
verortet sein humor habe ich gerne seine
buddhistisch völlig recht hat genau ich
bin ein echter wurdest und das haben sie
am liebsten eine illusion was wirklich
einmalig sein soll die zeit
mein sohn hat ganz anders als ich ein
unglaublich sonniges gemüt
das muss er von seiner mutter geerbt
haben
[Musik]
maximilian schulkarriere und seine
förderung polarisieren
nach den ersten medien auftreten vor
knapp zwei jahren ergoss sich ein
shitstorm über maximilian und seine
eltern wenn es die zuschauer dank lernt
durch der burg in weiler oma rennen oder
als beispiele das interessiert ihn
schlicht es interessierten klingelt an
die möglichkeit der
selbstverständlichkeiten händen zu jeder
veranstaltung etwas nach
geburtstag ist genügend kriegen die
umgebung sich gottwald hinterfuß alle
möglichkeiten hat man natürlich was wird
durch tröpfchen und und das angebots
mache aber das angebot rallye dakar und
dann muss man das akzeptieren
deswegen harmoniert darum vor dem
schlafengehen kosmologie stadt
kinderkanal macht ihr das nicht angst
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein
schwarzes loch trifft ist ungefähr
gleich null also das universum ist so
riesig vor allem weil es dreidimensional
ist in zweidimensionalen werde aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass uns einen
schwarzen locken auch trifft sehr viel
höher aber es gibt so wenig schwarze
löcher in unserer nähe und im
dreidimensionalen dass es uns genau
trifft dass es uns ein sagen kann dass
es so unwahrscheinlich dass man das
überhaupt kein ax macht meint ich glaube
es ist wirkliches geschenk es ist egal
ob es ist das geschenk das man dass man
selber der offensive für die maximilian
bio dadurch das ist aber auf ihres
älteren also es ist natürlich erfreut
damit ihm diskussion ist und gesehen und
auch so ist dass man das rad zurück
sondern zur leute sondern man wird
vortrag man muss antworten geben muss
auch mit den auseinandersetzungen in der
sache selber ist nachdenken wo bin ich
dankbar bin ich schön finde ja schön
sind wie siehst du deine zukunft
wie würdest du gerne leben möchtest du
im ausland leben der schweiz was das du
wissenschaftler werden möchtest du
familie haben möchtest du kinder werden
sicher haben
ich meine ich möchte nicht auf allein
gestellt sein ich bin jetzt hier in
einem dreier team und ich möchte auch
nicht auf mich allein gestellt sein das
kann sicher sagen aber mehr kann ich
auch eigentlich nicht sagen ich nehme es
wie es kommt keine zukunftsvorstellungen
nein machen zukunftswünsche auch keine
großen ich bin so zufrieden wie ich
gerade bin
[Musik]